bien mes chers collègues très heureux
que l'ambiance soit au beau fixe en tout
cas aussi souriante euh benah justement
du coup j'en profite puisque c'est notre
première commission pour vous souhaiter
à toutes et à tous et à vos
proches des vœux meilleurs vœux pour
l'année 2024 et puis vos collaborateurs
aussi euh moi les miens j'allais dire
que c'est peut-être je le dis sans sans
même un esprit partisan mais je pense
qu'on sera tous d'accord qu'on est un
peu plus l'occasion de voter le budget
de débattre du budget je pense qu'on
peut se proposer ça pour 2024
euh et ça serait ça serait à mon avis
satisfaisant bon comme on l'avait fait
au mois de septembre 2022 j'ai souhaité
faire un tour d'horizon des sujet
intéressant les finances publiques
locales en menant un cyle d'audition des
principales associations d'élus locaux
alors comme ça on s'y prend à l'avance
mais je pense qu'il est bien de de
pouvoir justement préparer la suite de
l'année avec un un certain nombre
d'audition
sur un sujet dont nous savons que il a
été quand même au cœur des discussions
de de ce dernier budget en tout cas en
commission donc cette audition de
l'association région de France est la
première de ce cycle nous avons
aujourd'hui donc le plaisir de recevoir
madame Carole Delga président de la
région ocitan de région de France on
poursuivra le cycle d'audition le
mercredi 31 janvier avec l'audition de
Monsieur François sauadet président de
l'Assemblée des départements de France
puis le mercredi 13 mars avec celle de
Monsieur David Linard et André
vice président et vice-président de
l'Association des maires de France et
des présidents
d'intercommunalité je remercie madame
Carole Delga d'avoir bien voulu répondre
la première à notre invitation et je lui
cède immédiatement la parole pour un
propos général avant d'engager ensuite
la discussion
merci
Monsieur monsieur le le président
monsieur le rapporteur général Mesdames
et Messieurs les les députés tout
d'abord bien sûr vous présenter mes mes
meilleurs vœux pour cette année 2024 que
cette année malgré un contexte complexe
au niveau
international malgré une urgence sociale
une urgence écologique une urgence
républicaine qu'elle soit quand même une
année d'espoir plaisir de de retrouver
la la commission des finances puisque en
2012 Quand j'avais été élu député je
j'étais à la à la commission des
finances certaines sans rappel voilà
donc merci Monsieur le présid président
d'avoir initié ces ces rencontres pour
pouvoir évoquer la question des des
finances local parce que nous avons de
nombreux enjeux sur notre pays en terme
de cohésence sociale en terme d'urgence
environnementale et le couple
État-Région est absolument indispensable
pour pouvoir relever ces défis les
régions ont eu eu de nouveaux défis à
relever à travers les nouvelles
compétences à travers le nouveau
périmètre pour une majorité d'entre
elles mais nous sommes
aujourd'hui confrontés à à une
difficulté
financière réelle et fortement
préoccupante nous avons toujours
souhaité les présidentes et les
présidents de région être dans une
position constructive pour pouvoir
répondre à la bataille de l'emploi les
chiffres des dernières années étaient
encourageant avec une baisse du taux de
chômage pour autant nous avons une
reprise légère qu'il convient de
surveiller et nous avons également des
personnes qui sont éloignées durablement
de l'emploiù nous donc nous devons
continuer à travailler ensemble pour
faire en sorte que la demande de nos
entreprises qui est forte sur la
question des des recrutements puisse
être
vraiment favorable sur encore ces
personnes qui sont éloignées de l'emploi
et ce qui nous demande des moyens
financiers fléchés de façon différente
puisque il y a de ça 8 ans c'était en
terme de nombre de places de formation
nous avions un taux de chômage qui était
très supérieur aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir
des formations beaucoup plus ciblées euh
sur l'acquisition de fondamentaux sur la
réappropriation de l'estime de soi par
des personnes qui ont connu de
nombreuses difficultés et la nécessité
de pouvoir former aussi aux nouveaux
métiers nouveaux métiers liés à la
transition écologique et énergétique
nouveaux métiers euh lié aux enjeux de
souveraineté industrielle donc un
partenariat euh indispensable entre
l'État et et les régions pour faire en
sorte aussi que nos politiques soient
adaptées euh au territoire euh parce que
la question de l'emploi
revê euh des réalités euh différentes
euh qui peuvent être différentes au sein
d'un même département il est absolument
indispensable d'avoir des politiques
adaptées sur euh les euh bassins de vie
sur les bassins d'emploi partenariat
également
État-Région indispensable de par la loi
sur la question des mobilité l'ensemble
des présidents de région hein les 18
présidents de région nous avons signé il
y a de ça près de 18 mois une demande
une tribune pour faire du ferrouiaire
l'axe prioritaire des mobilités en
France pas l'axe unique mais l'axe
priorita ire avec un investissement très
renforcé aussi bien du budget de l'État
que des crédits européens fléchés sur
l'ensemble de de ces actions il en va de
notre de nos
objectifs de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique il en va aussi
de notre souveraineté industriel parce
que la France dispose encore aujourd'hui
d'un temps d'avance sur les mobilités
mais que nous devons fortement renforcer
face à une concurrence internationale
exacerbée tout particulièrement lié au
groupe
CRC chinois et puis bien entendu toutes
les questions de l'éducation c'est pour
cela que nous demandons des pouvoirs
renforcés au niveau de l'orientation les
dispositifs liés au lycée à
l'apprentissage qui ont été euh modifié
en
2018 sont assis mais sur la question de
l'orientation nous jugeons là aussi
l'ensemble des présidents de région
qu'il y a une
méconnaissance selon le niveau social de
de nos enfants de la réalité des métiers
de la diversité des métiers et également
des cursus de de formation et afin de
lutter contre le déterminisme social il
est absolument indispensable d'avoir une
politique beaucoup plus offensive sur
les questions de l'orientation scolaire
et puis bien entendu tout le partenariat
état région que ça soit sur la mise en
œuvre du Zéro artificialisation net
concertation que nous sommes en train de
de mener que ça soit sur les objectifs
aussi de rénovation
énergétique des enjeux majeurs pour
notre pays pour l'Europe pour notre
planète et une situation financière qui
est particulièrement
préoccupante puisque nous avons augmenté
nos dépenses
d'investissement lié à la crise
sanitaire nous avons été partenaire de
l'ensemble des plans de relance et donc
nous avons augmenté entre 2019 et 2022
de 20 % nos dépenses d'investissement
parce qu'il était absolument nécessaire
de contrer les effets de la crise
sanitaire au point de vue économique en
aidant de façon significative les
entreprises pour l'adaptation aux
différents enjeux que ça soit sur la
question des économies d'énergie que ça
soit sur la question du du numérique que
ça soit sur l'investissement soutien
aussi de la commande publique à travers
l'investissement régional mais à
travers le soutien aux projets communaux
et intercommunaux donc des dépenses
d'investissement en hausse comme nous
nous sommes engagés auprès des
différents premiers ministres par voie
contractuelle et puis également une
explosion de nos dépenses de
fonctionnement liée à l'énergie comme
toutes les collectivités locales sur
leurs bâtiments publics mais également
une augmentation de nos dépenses de
carburant et là nous sommes les seules
collectivités locales à être touché à
travers les service de mobilité et nous
avons donc un impact
significatif sur nos nos capacité
d'investissement parce que cette
augmentation des des dépenses
d'investissement est couplée par une
augmentation de nos recettes de
fonctionnement que nous n'avons jamais
contesté mais qui ne sont pas
suffisantes par rapport à l'augmentation
de nos dépenses de fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire le différentiel sur l'année
2023 entre l'augmentation de nos
recettes de fonctionnement et de
dotation donc lié à la TVA et nos
dépenses de fonctionnement est d'un
milliard d'euros 1 milliard d'euros ce
qui demande à de nombreux présidents de
région de réduire la voilure au niveau
de de
l'investissement sinon il y aurait euh
une capacité de remboursement qui serait
inférieure et c'est pourquoi nous
alertons le Gouvernement sur ce
différentiel qui est significatif un
différentiel d'un milliard d'euros entre
la dynamique de recette de
fonctionnement et de et de nos dépenses
une nécessité d'amplifier
l'investissement que ça soit sur la
question du ferroviaire que ça soit
également sur la question de la
rénovation énergétique et pour autant
les régions nous avons été le seul
niveau de collectivité locale à ne pas
avoir une compensation sur
l'augmentation de nos dépenses d'énergie
puisque même les métropoles ont
bénéficié d'une aide de 100 millions
d'euros la situation financière des
métropoles est très satisfaisante et ils
ont une dynamique fiscale qui je le
rappelle ne bénéficie pas aux régions
puisque les régions sont dépendantes des
dotations de l'État à hauteur de 94 %.
la seule autonomie entre guillemets
fiscale que nous avant ce sont sur la
question des cartes grises et c'est une
dynamique fiscale qui est en baisse en
baisse constante et c'est pourquoi nous
avons demandé qu'il y ait une réfle
fletion sur ces impôts dit voitures qui
sont en
diminution ceux qui au niveau français
est plutôt une bonne nouvelle mais pour
autant qui pour nous représente un
manque à gagner donc nous avons plaidé
qu'il n'y ait pas de baisse des
dotations madame ellisabeth borne donc
ancien Premier ministre a décidé de ne
pas baisser les dotations sur la loi de
finances 2023 et sur la loi de finances
2024 alors que les précédentes années
nous avons eu 6 ans de baisse de nos
dotations constantes nous avons été là
aussi la seule strate de collectivité
locale avoir une baisse de dotation et
je voudrais rappeler une baisse
significative donc sur nos finances en
2017 et 2018 puisque il y a eu le la le
transfert de la compétence développement
économique entre les départements et euh
les régions et euh le différentiel cette
compétence développement économique éta
estimée à un milliard 6 nous avons une
compensation de 600 millions et nous
avions accepté ce différentiel d'un
milliard de par la dynamique que nous
allions percevoir de la TVA donc
l'argument qui nous est souvent donné
sur cette dynamique de TVA qui existe
qui est moindre quand même que que prévu
avait déjà été pris en compte au moment
de de cette décision en
2017 et nous nous regrettons qu'à chaque
fois cela nous soit donné parce que cela
nous met dans une situation
financière difficile
Rappelz également que la
structuration de nos dotations liées à
la TVA maintenant s'approche de celle
des départements puisque nous avons les
régions nos dotations qui sont liées à à
plus de 34 % à la TVA avec les nouvelles
réformes sur les doation et la fiscalité
des départements ils sont à 28 % donc
c'est une structuration qui est assez
équivalente donc les arguments de la
dynamique de la TVA bénéficient aussi
bien aux régions qu'au département et la
différence c'est que l'autre dynamique
fiscale qui bénéficie au dép appartement
les les DMTO ont été en progression sont
aujourd'hui en baisse mais avec une très
forte dynamique et avec un système que
vous connaissez de
capacité de réserve qui était offert aux
départements qui avaient vu une forte
augmentation de leur des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux et que certains
départements ont pu mettre en œuvre
alors que nous les régions nous n'avons
pas d'autres dynamique fiscale et comme
je le rappelais les impôts voitures sont
en diminution donc c'est cette situation
nous amène à demander au gouvernement
que nous puissions avoir un Pact
d'engagement sur un fond de 350 millions
nous avions commencer les discussions
avec ellisabeth borne sur le mois de
décembre nous allons les poursuivre dès
la fin du mois de janvier avec Monsieur
le Premier Ministre Atal puisque je dois
le le rencontrer le 30 le 29 ou le 30
janvier voilà enfin en fin de mois pour
que nous puissions avoir un un fond
d'investissement nous ne demandons pas
comme C a été mis en place dans la loi
de finances
2024 une enveloppe au niveau des du
fonctionnement comme les départements
hein je fais référence à la fameuse
enveloppe de 230 millions nous demandons
un fond en investissement pour pouvoir
répondre aux enjeux de transition
écologique et énergétique puisque les
régions ne sont pas éligibles au fond
vert qui a été mis en place et dont
bénéficie essentiellement les communes
et les intercommunalités donc un travail
que nous devons mener avec le nouveau
gouvernement pour permettre aux régions
de continuer à investir pour atteindre
des objectifs qu'il soi européens ou
français
amener des services à la population dans
un pays profondément divisé et
profondément inquiet pour
l'avenir cette proposition donc sera
travaillée elle sera complétée par donc
la demande réitérer de pouvoir
travailler sur une nouvelle fiscalité
pour se substit situé aux impôts
voitures qui n donc qui nous permettra
d'avoir là aussi une dynamique donc
fiscale l'ensemble de ces propositions
sont partagé donc par tous les
présidents des régions de France et nous
voulons continuer à investir massivement
je rappelle qu'en moyenne pour les les
régions les différences peuvent être
vraiment assez significative d'une
région à l'autre mais en dépense de
fonctionnement n 1/ers n dépenses de
fonctionnement sont consacrés au rail et
donc pour
laasncf et 1/4 de l'investissement sur
la question des mobilités ce qui sont
voilà pour nous les mobilités et
l'éducation les deux budgets majeurs ces
chiffres sont pour les mobilités hors
Île-de-France mob
parce que le dispositif est spécifique
et un financement qui est
autonome juste dans mes mots conclusifs
également mettre en exerg la hausse des
tarifs des péages ferroviaires qui sont
significatifs qui
seraiit dans ce qui est prévu de + 24 %
en 2024 et 2026 dans la tribune que nous
avions présenté l'ensemble des
présidents de région nous demandions un
choc sur l'offre ferroviaire avec un
investissement à hauteur de 100
milliards d'euros parce que je rappelle
que le budget de l'État français sur le
ferroviaire est significativement plus
faible que le budget par exemple de
l'État
allemand nous sommes voilà du du simple
au au triple rappeler également
que sur le matériel roulant vert je
pense en particulier au trains à
hydrogène en France ce sont les régions
qui financent à hauteur des 2/ers les
trains à hydrogène en Allemagne c'est
financé à hauteur uniquement d'un/ers et
de plus le système de financement du du
ferroviaire est peu incitatif à proposer
plus de train pour nos concitoyens parce
que plus on fait circuler de trains et
plus on paye de péag donc si on était
sur une vision strictement budgétaire
les présidents de région n'auraient
aucun intérêt à proposer une offre
ferroviaire significative donc nous
demandons à ce que le système du
financement du ferroviaire soit
complètement revu il y a la question du
versement mobilité où il a été accordé
pour Île-de-France mobilité un
complément du versement mobilité donc je
pense qu'il est
ant qu'il y ait un dispositif d'égalité
dans dans ce pays et que cette
possibilité qui a été offert au
territoire franilien puisse être étendu
à l'ensemble des territoires de de la
République il y a également la nécessité
de regarder la fin des concessions
autoroutières puisque dès 2028 il y aura
ces contrats qui vont arriver à terme et
voir quels sont les financements nous
avons aussi les montages juridique sur
le système ferroviaire à étudier du type
société euh donc de de financement comme
cela a été mis en place pour les trois
LGV qui sont donc Marseille Nice
Toulouse Bordeaux bordeau Dax et
Montpellier Perpignan où également
s'inspirer des dispositifs de la Société
des grands projets anciennement société
du du Grand Paris donc vraiment ces
alertes pour vous indiquer que le
système ferroviaire français pour les
présidents de Région doit être
complètement revu pour faire en sorte
que nous puissions euh avoir une
régénération euh
de notre nos infrastructures de
transport qui soi significatives euh
pour aussi des réouvertures de lignes
dans certaines régions pour également un
investissement dans le matériel roulant
pour pouvoir augmenter les capacités
d'emport vous signalez également le gros
retard en matière euh de signalisation
euh sur le système ferroviaire français
et la nécessité euh absolue euh de euh
noous équipés en matériel ERTMS euh
comme cela est mené euh dans d'autres
pays et puis également mener euh une
réflexion sur la question euh tarifaire
puisque un groupe de travail avait été
mis en place sur le fameux pass inspiré
du modèle allemand qui est à 49 € par
mois les travaux sont suspendus
maintenant depuis euh depuis un mois
sachant que dans certaines régions et en
l'occurrence à occitan le Pass existe à
45 € pour les salariés déduction faite
de la participation euh employeur et
qu'il est absolument nécessaire de
travailler et sur une tarification
incitative et également sur le
dispositif du billet unique en France
nous sommes très pénalisé par cette
division de la chaîne des transports qui
ne favorise pas ni les mobilité douce ni
les transports collectifs voilà monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
les députés les éléments que je
souhaitais vous présenter merci de cette
présentation et de ces propositions euh
au nom de l'Association des régions de
France euh on va euh donc euh moi-même
puis le rapporteur général vous poser un
certain nombre de questions on vous
donnera la parole on passera au groupe
et ensuite aux questions supplémentaires
moi j'ai quatre questions euh
oui c'est à quatre questions euh d'abord
il y a une question d'actualité qui est
liée à ce qui se passe au niveau des
inondations dévastatrices dans les EAU
DE FRANCE euh je vais puiez nous dire
euh quels sont pour vous les moyens dont
disposent les régions pour lutter contre
les effets dramatiques du changement
climatique est-ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes est-ce qu'il faut renforcer
votre rôle dans ce domaine moi j'ai
toujours pensé que la question
de de la transition écologique passait
aussi par le fait de prévoir
suffisamment de ressources pour les les
réparations j'allais dire mais aussi
l'anticipation donc comment vous
analysez vous analysz cette question une
part du produit de la fiscalité
transféré aux région la titic CPE et la
taxe les certificat d'immatriculation
est amené à diminuer les prochaines
années pensez-vous qu'il faille modifier
le panier de ressources des régions et
le cas échéant qu le ressources
substitué à cette fiscalité peu
dynamique et assise en plus sur des
activités peantes le troisème thème et
vous venez d'en parler c'est la question
ferroviaire vous avez rappelé le le les
annonces y compris de Madame born de la
premierre ministre l'expremier ministre
sur les les 100 milliards sans qu'on
sache trop justement moi c'était un des
problèmes que je voyais qui euh qui
finançait ces 100 milliards donc là vous
avez détaillé un certain nombre de
problèmes j'ai noté notamment la
question du pH
ferroviaire comme un des soucis mais euh
pensez-vous que la participation de
l'État à cet égard devrait être plus
importante y compris pour aider les
régions et en lien avec les nouveaux CP
donc vous en avez parlé mais j'aimerais
que vous reveniez sur les sur peut-être
les les sources des financements
supplémentaires qui sont nécessaires euh
il apparaît que à la différence des
autres collectivités territoriales les
régions n'ont pas été compensées par
l'État pour le coût de l'inflation
qu'elles ont eu à subir c'était une un
échange qu'on a eu au moment du Congrès
des Maires justement au moment on a
parlé de votevenenue à combien
estimez-vous ce surcout pour les régions
et a-t-il eu une incidence sur le niveau
d'investissement des régions voilà mes
quatre questions je passe la parole au
rapporteur
général merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente euh permettez-moi
aussi de de souhaiter bonne année à tout
le monde d'être très heureux de vous
recevoir à double titre évidemment
puisque nous sommes sur la même région
d'abord vous remercier sur
le la dimension constructive m vous
présentez les choses avec l'État et je
crois que le destin effectivement des
régions et de l'État sont sont liés sur
des sujets qui intéresse nos concitoyens
que ce soit le transport que ce soit la
transition écologique que ce soit les le
niveau d'investissement euh et et comme
vous je je ne partie de ceux qui
opposent l'État et des collectivités
territoriales et face au défis que nous
avons et vous les avez rappelé vous en
avez rappelé en tous les cas quelquesuns
c'est ensemble que nous trouverons les
bonnes solutions je je partage pas
complètement votre diagnostic sur sur
les finances des des régions et en
particulier quand vous dites que les
dotations ont baissé je je vais vous
prendre deux
éléments la première c'est que la la
dotation globale de fonctionnement en
2017 nous l'avons remplacé pour les
régions par une fraction de de TVA et là
où au contraire l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales sont
retrouvé avec unee dotation qui était
figé alors qu' a augmenté depuis
maintenant 2 ans la la l'équivalent de
la dotation globale de fonctionnement a
augmenté fortement puisqu'elle est
passée entre 2017 et 2022 de 4,1
milliards à 5 milliards donc c'est une
augment mentation de 900 millions autre
exemple ça n'est pas directement une
dotation bien évidemment mais c'est la
CVAE c'est le soutien qu'a apporté
l'État aux régions pendant la crise du
du covid à votre demande à la demande
des régions la CVE a été remplacé par
une fraction de TVA si pourquoi pourquoi
ça pourquoi cette demande en 2022 parce
que
évidemment vu la crise du covid tout le
monde anticipé une baisse très
significative sur 2 ans de la CVAE euh
et effectivement si la CVAE n'ait pas
été remplacé par la la TV1 la cvre
aurait baissé à peu près de 500 millions
d'euros et la remplacé par la TVA fait
au contraire que cette ressource a
augmenté et l'écart entre la fraction de
TVA que vous avez aujourd'hui et si vous
avez gardé la CVE est de l'ordre de 1,2
1,3 milliard d'euros donc c'était une
demande je pense que c'était très bien
l'objectif c'était là de soutenir le
niveau d'investissement des régions et
je crois que là c'est une ustration
assez claire solante et tribuchante si
vous me permettez du soutien euh de
l'État euh aux régions euh qui a permis
donc euh de rectifier euh euh la
trajectoire financière des régions au au
total euh pendant la période
2017-2022 les les recettes
investissement et et et et et
fonctionnement des régions augmenté de
16 % plus que vos dépenses et donc la
capacité d'autofinancement brut a elle
augmenté de 17 % sur la période vous
avez raison de souligner que 23 risque
d'être un peu moins bon mais on en pas
encore tout à fait les chiffres mais
voilà sur cette période là la dynamique
des recettes des des régions a été
supérieure à la dynamique des recettes
de l'État par exemple
euh pourevenir sur sur mes mes questions
[Musique]
euh été 2020 il y a eu un accord entre
Jean Castex alors Premier ministre et
les régions de de France euh l'État
s'est engagé sur un filet de sécurité
pour l'autre maire ce qui a été ce qui a
été fait l'État s'est engagé sur 600
millions d'investissements
supplémentaires ce qui a été fait et
l'État s'est engagé sur substituer la
CVAE par la TVA ce qui ce qui a été fait
les régions euh devaient de leur côté
mettre sur pied ce qu'on a appelé un
serpent budgétaire de manière à
euh augmenter la résilience des finances
des des euh des régions et on sait que
c'est un un vrai sujet est-ce que euh ce
serpent budgétaire est est en place euh
les régions devaent mettre un un système
de péréquation euh entre elles cette
péréquation devait commencer à 1 % et
progresser progressivement jusqu'à 2 %
c'est extrêmement important pour les
régions les plus défavorisées ou les
plus pauvres en particulier je pense à
nos con collègue d'outrem aujourd'hui
cette péréquation plutôt aux alentour de
08 % est-ce que vous avez prévu
d'augmenter son poids entre les régions
puis enfin le trème point c'était 20
milliards d'investissement entre 2021 et
2027 dans le cadre des des CPR moi j'ai
pas de visibilité est-ce que pour nous
donner un peu de visibilité sur le
niveau d'investissement dans le cadre de
C de c c per des des régions enfin
dernière question euh sur sur le le
financement moi je
je aussi je je je je salue votre votre
ouverture je pense qu'il y a une vraie
question de financement des
collectivités territoriales en
particulier sur le niveau départemental
et d'une certaine manière sur le niveau
régional au regard de l'autonomie
financière et fiscale que vous avez
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous seriez prêt
à à un à une dotation annuelle voté par
le Parlement comme ça se fait un peu en
Allemagne ou est-ce que c'est un modèle
que vous excluez absolument et que vous
êtes plutôt
aujourd'hui satisfaite du panier de
recette que vous avez je vous remercie
Carole delg pour les
réponses donc merci donc je vais
commencer à à par répondre au question
de Monsieur le le
président sur les catastrophes
climatiques que nous connaissons en
effet sur les inondations qu'on
connu la des des haut-de France ou que
ça soit sur les phénomènes de
sécheresse je pense que en effet nous
devons être dans des politiques
d'anticipation beaucoup plus fortes et
c'est pour ça j'ai parlé du
développement des transports en commun
sur la question de la rénovation
énergétique et puis également sur des
mesures de de prévention pour nous les
présidents de région le premier frein et
la multiplicité des
acteurs c'est une véritable cacophonie
euh sur euh la multiplicité euh des euh
des des acteurs qui interviennent dans
dans ce domaine j'ai pu euh le vérifier
je dirais malheureusement lors des
inondations de l'ode il y a de ça euh
quelques années et c'est pour cela que
j'avais pris la décision en tant que
présidente de région de confier le fond
d'intervention de la région au
département de l'ode pour ne pas
multiplier un acteur euh supplémentaire
nous avons besoin d'avoir beaucoup plus
euh de simplicité euh sur les actions de
de prévention euh que ça soit sur euh
les dispositifs euh de curage des cours
d'eau ou des canaux puisqu'on est sur un
système de euh de canaux sur les les les
haut de France et euh nous devons euh
également avoir une question un peu du
type chef de fil pour vraiment on peut
avoir après plusieurs intervenants parce
que les travaux sont à à des niveaux qui
sont différents certains qui peuvent
être à une échelle très local où il est
possible tout à fait que
l'intercommunalité agisse mais d'autres
qui sont plus à des échelles de Bass
inversant où il vaut mieux avoir des
collectivités voilà qui sont avec une
iscise financière plus large
donc la la position des régions de
France c'est d'avoir moins d'intervenant
et une façon de chef de fila pour qu'il
y ait après une bonne
organisation du qui fait quoi nous avons
également des euh contraintes très très
fortes au niveau des autorisations
réglementair pour pouvoir réaliser des
des travaux avec des temps euh qui qui
sont très très longs au point de vue
administratif et qui demanderait de par
les les catastrophes climatiques qui
sont récurrentes à être
raccourci
sur la question du panier de ressources
dans mon intervention j'y avais un peu
répondu en disant que notre panier de
ressources fiscales lié à l'automobile
et voilà dépasser qu'il est en
diminution et et nous partageons
vraiment la nécessité que il soit en
diminution pour les questions de
pollution mais pour autant il doit être
substitué par une autre part de d'impôts
et les présidents de région nous sommes
plutôt favorables à un impôt lié à la
dynamique économique parce que je pense
qu'il est essentiel d'avoir une relation
entre entre les actions et la fiscalité
que touchent les collectivités locales
sur la question du principe de
l'autonomie fiscale ou de l'autonomie
financière là pour répondre à monsieur
le rapporteur général du
budget les présidents de de région sont
favorables à une autonomie financière en
Allemagne il y a une garantie
constitutionnelle c'est-à-dire que la
baisse qu'on pu connaître euh les
régions de façon très significative dans
la dotation euh et je vous rappellerai
les discussions qu'il y avait pu avoir à
la commission des finances sur la loi de
finances 2018 euh n'aurait pas pu se
produire en Allemagne parce que vous
avez une garantie constitutionnelle qui
permet de bénéficier d'une dotation qui
est stabilisée et qui ne pouvait pas
varier dans les mêmes proportions que ça
a été le cas dans notre pays euh en 2018
sur la question de l'autonomie fiscale
au niveau de l'ensemble des présidents
de région il n'y a pas une position
unanimeilà pour ma part moi je suis
favorable à une autonomie fiscale que je
pense quand on est dans un exécutif
local il est
nécessaire d'avoir aussi la
responsabilité de répondre de sa
politique
fiscale sur la question de
l'investissement ferroviaire les
présidents de région nous avions demandé
100 milliards mais pour les 10
prochaines années le plan présenté par
Madame ellisabeth borne c'est 5
milliards sur les 17 prochaines
années pardon
oui oui oui i voilà pardon j'avais pas
bien entendu non mais déjà vous indiquez
que que que les annonces ne
correspondent l'annonce de Madame
première ministre n'était pas sur la le
le même temps
calendaire également sur
l'investissement ferroviaire il y a la
question euh des services express euh
donc métropolitains les fameux RER
métropolitains et euh leur inscription
dans les CPER volet mobilité euh au
niveau du volet mobilité des CPR ils ne
sont pas tous conclus euh il y en a à
peu près 1/ers qui sont signés qui sont
finalisés avec les régions et il en
manque euh encore 2 tiers parce que nous
avons un désaccord avec le ministère des
Transports sur
l'enveloppe financière euh et et qui
porte euh tout particulièrement mais pas
uniquement sur les réseaux Express
métropolitain et pour et puis sur des
lignes d'aménagement du territoire le
différentiel euh entre la dynamique de
nos recettes de fonctionnement que nous
n'avons jamais euh contesté euh et euh
nos dépenses de de fonctionnement ce
différentiel sur année 2023 il va être
de 1 milliard d'euros voilà il va être
la certifié dans les prochains jours 1
milliard d'euros 1 milliard d'euros les
régions sont bien gérées elles ne
s'approchent pas des 9 ans qui sont la
nombre d'années de capacité de de
désendettement ell sont pas 8 et demi en
moyenne on est plutôt aux alentours de
de de 5 années mais pour autant euh sur
les budget 2024 il il va y avoir et il
nous sommes en début d'année donc mais
dans l'exécution du budget 2024 il y
aura bien entendu des des conséquences
parce que nous ne pouvons pas 2 années
de suite supporter un tel différentiel
et je la rappelle quand les régions
investissent moins c'est un
investissement moindre euh pour la
question euh de l'emploi pour la
question des mobilités pour la question
aussi des énergies euh renouvelables
nous avons réussi en effet comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le rapporteur
général à augmenté notre capacité
d'investissement dans la
contractualisation que nous avons pris
avec le gouvernement lié à la situation
exceptionnelle euh de cette crise
sanitaire cela a été possible parce que
les régions en particulier les régions
fusionnées ont pu faire des économies
sur les dépenses de fonction
en mutualisant de de nombreux services
en
particulier sur les fonction
support quand j'indique en effet que
nous avons une baisse de dotation c'est
parce que cette dynamique de TVA elle
avait été anticipée elle avait été
anticipée dès l'année 2017 et c'est pour
ça que dans la négociation sur le
transfert des compétences économies nous
avions accepté de avoir une compensation
à hauteur de 600 millions au lieu des 1
milliard 6 donc on ne peut pas à chaque
année nous ressortir la dynamique de TVA
on ne vend qu'une fois hein c'est un
adage oxitant mais on ne reçoit la
recette qu'une
fois également et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on ne peut pas recycler cette cet
argument là et puis je tiens à dire que
la structuration maintenant des
dotations et laique fiscale entre les
départements et les régions sont très
avoisinantes nous avons une
structuration qui est fort différente
avec le bloc communal c'est pour ça que
je ne je n'engage pas de de comparaison
mais nous avons quand je discute avec
mes collègues présidents de département
et qui me font part et en réalité bien
entendu hein de la baisse de la DCRTP
pour certains je me permets de le
rappeler quand même de l'explosion qu'il
y a eu euh de pas de la DCRTP de DMTO
pardon euh l'explosion de des des MTO je
me permets de leur rappeler l'explosion
qu'ils ont eu en recette et de la
capacité qu'ils avaient aussi à à mener
des réserves nous explosions que nous
n'avons pas connu sur la question de la
contractualisation en 2020 sur les
différents plans de relance bien sûr les
régions ont été au rendez-vous ont
parfaitement honoré leurs engagements et
par exemple sur un dispositif territoire
d'industrie souvent les régions ont même
investi plus que l'État c'est le cas de
de l'Occitanie et donc là sur cela vous
nous pourrons vous vous transmettre les
euh chiffres de des réalisation que nous
avons pu mener h
oui toujours sur la question des
dotations je vous rappelle quand même
que les baisses sur aussi bien la
DCRTP que sur la compensation des frais
de gestion euh ont été euh
significatives et que de par par une une
mécanique qui avait été mise en place au
moment de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle les deux régions les
plus impactés pour la diminution de la
DCRTP sont les deux régions les plus
pauvres de France c'est-à-dire haau-de
France et ooccitanie et c'est pour cela
que je faisais valoir à chaque fois
qu'il y avait une baisse de la DCRTP que
la région î-de-france n'était nullement
impactée alors qu'en revanche les deux
régions les plus impactées étai celles
qui avait un niveau de revenus par
habitant les plus faibles et que cela
était
particulièrement injuste
h donc ça oui je ni parlé
euh je regarde si j'ai oublié
voilà sur la question des péréquations
voilà je vous ai j'ai pas
répondu nous avons mis en place un
dispositif de péréquation avec le
premier ministre Jean Castex qui donc
est est en cours qui continue jusqu'en
2027 de mémoire je oui enfin il il est
pérenne donc et en effet nous avons fait
un effort supérieur de péréquation
vis-à-vis des territoires d'outrem et
cela me permet également de rappeler la
demande de l'ensemble des présidents de
région
d'augmenter les dotations pour les
territoires d'outrem qui ont un
fonctionnement de des dotation un peu
différent des régions métropolitaines de
par l'état des infrastructures
hospitalières de par également les
difficultés de mobilité pour ces
territoires et la Corse en a également
pu en bénéficier dans le nouveau
mécanisme de solidarité c'est un
prélèvement
pardon oui 8 % en effet ne concerne que
la Corse et les et les outresmèes et ça
c'est à l'unanimité des présidents de
région métropolitaine que nous l'avons
mis en place il me semble que j'ai
répondu à l'ensemble des questions bien
merci on va passer aux orateurs de
groupe 2 minutes chacun Renaissance
bedois mournet merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
madame la présidente de région d'abord
je vous remercie pour votre exposé et
puis d'avoir rappelé qu'aujourd'hui
toutes les politiques publiques sont
partenarial entre l'État et les
collectivités et qui il y a pas à à
opposer les les niveaux alors je veux
pas trop revenir sur la situation
financière ça a été dit une épargne
brute qui est qui est là et pour autant
des investissements que vous avez portés
je veux y voir quand même effectivement
un soutien de l'État non négligeable sur
la dynamique de la TVA ces dernières
années mais sans mésestimer non plus
évidemment l'inflation et notamment sur
les les prix de l'énergie alors je
voudrais pointer en fait au fond une une
certaine inadéquation on des recettes
quand même des régions par rapport à
certains objectifs d'abord effectivement
euh vous avez une grande partie de
recettes qui sont liées à la
consommation de pétrole ti CPE les
cartes grises dont on sait effectivement
que le pouvoir de taux est est limité et
puis les recettes de TVA par définition
qui est nationale et donc des régions
qui sont en augmentation démographique
peut-être sont moins que compensé c'est
le cas chez nous en Occitanie alors
est-ce que vous avez réfléchi au titre
de région de France pour a des
propositions pour rééquilibrer les
choses tout en respectant bien
évidemment notre trajectoire de
redressement des des finances publiques
qui sont pas absolument brillantes
deuxième élément c'est le bilan qu'on
peut tirer de la loi notre de 2015 et
donc la structuration de ces grandes
régions quels sont si vous pouvez nous
nous communiquer le chiffre les les
économies d'échelle qui ont pu être
effectué à la à la fusion de ces régions
est-ce qu'il y a encore des marges
devant nous en particulier sur peut-être
les dépenses de formation
professionnelle est-ce que vous avez un
bilan comparé entre les régions sur
celles qui ont fait le choix d'un prix
que porté exclusivement par le Conseil
Régional C qui sont portés par
pôleemploi ou ou ceux qui ont un modèle
hybride et si vous me permettez monsieur
le Président un dernier mot sur le volet
transport vous avez évoqué le la
proposition de lois zouési est-ce que
vous pensez pouvoir la déployer en
dehors des métropoles je pense en
particulier à notre territoire
d'industrie lac potarb qui qui aurait
mériterait peut-être ce RER je vous
remercie pour votre attention merci
Frédéric cabrolier pour le rassemblement
national madame la la Présidente je vais
vous parler de la la fusion des régions
que vous avez bien connu euh un rapport
de la Cour des comptes qui date de 2020
que que vous devez connaître indique que
la fusion des régions a vu les dépenses
globales à périmètre constant augmenté
en moyenne à peu près de 200 millions
d'euros et on est loin donc des 10
milliards d'euros qui avaient été
envisagé lors lors de la réforme alors
si on prend justement cette période 2015
à 2019 qui permet d'exclure les crises
sanitaires et énergétiques on voit que
les dépenses de fonctionnement ont
augmenté plus fortement dans les régions
qui ont fusionné par rapport aux autres
c'est en moyenne à peu près 20 % euh les
tout ça duû essentiellement aux dépenses
de personnel qui ont augmenté à peu près
10 % en moyenne si je prends l'ocitan
c'est même 20 % ça représente 60
millions d'euros bon vous avez fait
comme les autres présidents de région
vous avez harmonisé bien sûr par le les
régimes indemnitaires dans les deux
régions les recettes de fonctionnement
elles ont augmenté un peu moins malgré
la perte de pouvoir de Tau dont vous
avez parlé effectivement vous aviez vous
avez la TI CPE et vous aviez vous avez
la les carte grise le tarif des cartes
grises et là aussi vous avez harmonisé
par le haut puisque par exemple en en
Occitanie euh il y avait en MIDI pyrénée
34 € chevaux fiscaux pour midi pyrénée
et vous avez avait harmonisé à 44 € au
niveau de langdoc Rousillon alors comme
l'épargne brute bien entendu a peu
augmenté entre 2015 et et 2019 et bien
et comme les dépenses d'investissement
vous l'avez rappelé ont augmenté en
moyenne de plus 20 % en tout cas sur
cette période essentiellement dû au
transfert de la compétence transport
ferroviaire et bien c'est la dette qui
en général a augmenté alors en 2015
l'encs de dette de toutes les régions
c'était 24 milliards d'euros c'était
déjà multiplié par 10 par rapport à 86
sur la période donc 2015-29 il y a seul
TR régions sur 13 ont réduit leur
endettement donc le bilan quel bilan
faites-vous par rapport à cette fusion
des régions vous qui avez bien connu
donc la fusion des régions merci
Sébastien R pour la franç soumise merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente et je dire à l'ensemble de
mes collèges bonanado voilà donc je vous
remercie pour pour le tableau que vous
avez brossé de la situation des régions
après cette année 2023 qui a été qui a
d'abord et et aussi durement frappé nos
nos concitoyens alors une première
question on revient sur sur certains
thèmes sur celui du degré de liberté des
régions si on retient la définition
d'autonomie fiscale qui est porté par
Jean-René casenu en se limitant au
pouvoir sur les taux l'autonomie fiscale
des régions n'est que de 9 %. en clair
les régions n'ont pas la main sur
l'impôt sur la taxe sur l'essence ou sur
la TVA par ailleurs vous plaidez pour un
pouvoir règlementaire accru confié aux
régions et donc de ce que j'appellerai
moi une dérive de notre modèle
républicain vers un système landur
allemand alors ainsi n'y a-t-il pas une
contradiction importante à confier plus
d'autonomie réglementaire au région
alors que les élus régionaux ne sont pas
responsables de la levée de l'impôt ce
qui est et vous l'avez dit un des
éléments fondateurs de la responsabilité
politique devant les électeurs autre
question euh les deux premiers postes
budgétaires de la région son l'éducation
et les transports on l'a dit le scolaire
et et TER nous avons Moné ça a été
rappelé le déploiement des services
express régionaux métropolitains qui
doivent connecter les territoires ruraux
aux villes notamment avec des trains
estimez-vous que ces projets soi
aujourd'hui finançable à la hauteur des
besoins euh enfin la région Occitanie
est la seule région qui a fait le choix
de lignes à très grande vitesse 320 km à
l'HE alors que les lignes grand vitesse
250 km àhe sont suffisantes pour gagner
du temps et permettreent de faire
quelques milliards d'économies par
exemple all long gant la A9 plutôt qu'en
construisant un viaduc ne pensez-vous
pas qu'il est préférable de
redimensionner certains grands projets
afin d'investir dans les déplacements du
quotidien moi sur ma c'est une attente
très forte sur ma circonscription les
citoyens les élus en fait qui juge que
par exemple la ville de Montpellier
n'est plus est de plus en plus
inaccessible pour prendre les mots de de
Gilles Savari et il préférerait attendre
finalement perdre quelques minutes 8
minutes dans un TGV plutôt et gagner 30
minutes sur leur déplacement pour
arriver à la gare merci merci
euh Marie-Christine Dallos pour les
républicains oui merci monsieur le
président madame la Présidente j'ai une
remarque un constat et deux questions la
première remarque c'est que
euh vous avez tout à l'heure parlé au
début de votre propos de la question du
retour à l'emploi et je me suis
interrogé alors c'est vrai que vous êtes
chef de fil en matière de d'économie les
régions on est d'accord en terme de
compéten sauf que le retour à l'emploi à
part la formation qui est dans votre
champ de compétenence tout le reste
c'est soit l'état politique régalienne
avec maintenant France travail ou France
compétence je sais plus enfin France
quelque chose et puis parallèlement les
régions avec les départements avec le
RSA mais je me suis posé la question
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes sur ce
retour à l'emploi alors que normalement
c'est pas votre champ de compétence est
qu'il a un impact sérieux sur vos frais
sur vos budget de fonctionnement et je
le constate dans toutes les régions de
France ça c'était ma première remarque
la deuxième le constat que je fais vous
avez parlé du fait qu'il y avait un/3
des CP qui avaient été signés oui je
trouve ça déplorable en région bourgonne
franchecté par exemple les CP ça fait
des années qu'on passe à côté parce
qu'ils ne sont pas prêts pas est pas
affiné et je pense que c'est un vrai gâi
d'argent public donc on peut pas être
crédible en demandant de l'argent public
si parallèlement on n'est pas capable de
de mettre en place des actions dans le
cadre du CP maises deux questions
maintenant le décompte définitif de vos
demandes j'aimerais bien que vous me
fassiez les additions parce que j'ai
compris qu'il y avait différentes
différents volets donc quel est le
montant global de la demande aujourd'hui
des régions financièrement parce que
c'est de la dette un futur et puis une
autre question vous parlez dans votre
dans votre PLF 2024 de substituer des
recettes assises sur la fiscalité
automobile qui a une proposition de la
de la Cour des comptes du président de
la la Cour des comptes qu'est-ce que
vous envisagez quel montant serait
nécessaire sous quelle forme parce que
je pense que c'est important de préciser
exactement sur la fiscalité automobile
c'est toute la tarification carte grise
ou pas je sais pas j'aimerais bien que
vous puissiez nous dire ce qu'il en est
merci merci euh gessm pour le groupe
démocrate merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente je vous remercie
d'avoir quitté votre belle région pour
nous rejoindre en commission des
finances vous voyez le soleil vous a
suivi jusqu'ici et qui dit soleil dit
verdissement verdissement des finances
locales la loi de finances pour 2024
inst l'obligation pour les collectivités
et les groupements de plus de 3500
habitants de se doter d'un budget vert
annexé au compte administratif ou au
compte financier unique à partir de
2024 tout d'abord alors qu'au Sénat
beaucoup de parlementaires ont émis des
réticences au sujet du caractère
obligatoire de la mesure nous pensons au
groupe démocrate que le verdissement des
finances publiques locales passe tout
d'abord par l'utilisation de référentiel
comptables partagés alors que
conformément à la article 191 de la loi
de finances des concertations
entre gouvernement et les élus doivent
permettre d'établir le décret
d'application de cette mesure ainsi que
l'arrêté fixant le modèle de l'État
annexé avez-vous d'ors et déjà des
éléments à nous communiquer pour
garantir l'utilité la pertinence et
l'efficacité de cette budgétisation
verte je vous remercie bien c'est déjà
le printemps avec Luc gessmar Christine
pirzb pour le groupe socialiste
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la Présidente cher Carole pour
pour votre
présentation j'avais moi aussi une
question mais elle m'a été piquée si je
dire par le président coqurel donc je ne
reviendrai pas dessus vous y avez
répondu mais pour le coup je suppose que
vous avez rencontré notre collègue Eric
Verz qui a été comme vous le savez
chargé d'une mission sur la
décentralisation il l' a été je crois en
novembre donc je pense qu'il a fait le
tour en tout cas des associations d'élus
et j'aimerais si si c'est possible
euh savoir dans sa lettre de mission
concernant les régions euh queles sont
vos propositions par rapport à sa lettre
de mission et peut-être une deuxième
question on a objectivement une
dégradation des services
publics certaines euh je prendrai deux
exemples que ce soit par exemple dans le
domaine de la santé ou des transports un
exemple Clermont Paris on faisait en 2h
3/4 il y a 20 ans aujourd'hui on est à
3h30 cette dégradation elle est sensible
et elle est rapide euh on a
euh un gouvernement qui nous dit pas de
prélèvement supplémentaires pas de
ressources publiques supplémentaires
donc reste effectivement la source des
économies moi je voudrais savoir quel
domaine partager entre l'État et les
région
pourrait faire l'objet d'une
simplification et d'une compétence
exclusive au bénéfice des régions est-ce
que vous avez identifier des domaines
qui pourrai effectivement parce que
redondant parce que doublons générer des
économies générer peut-être de la
simplification assurément et qui
pourrait
être offert exclusivement par par les
régions merci François je je l' vais
pour horizon
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente de de vous livrer à cet
exercice moi je souhaiterais attirer
votre attention
sur l'ombre de choc à venir de la crise
immobilière et notamment sur le
ralentissement de la production neuve de
logement dans notre pays vous êtes
porteur de la compétence développement
économique et et alerté par les
entreprises par des entreprises
présentes même dans votre région je
elles sont très inquiètes sur leur
devenir et je souis savoir quel regard
vous portez sur les conséquences de
cette crise déjà d'un point de vue
économique et en matière d'emploi
ensuite je souhaiterais savoir comment
euh euh dans l'accompagnement de la
transition énergétique vous accompagnez
euh la formation en matière de
réhabilitation de logement puisqu'on
sait que les personnels qui aujourd'hui
produisent du logement neuf ne sont pas
les mêmes que ceux qui les réhabilitent
et comment vous avez orienté vos
priorités sur ce sujet et puis une
question qui est peut-être très à la
marge et mes collègues m'en pardonneront
euh vous savez que on parle de tenue
scolaire identique donc dans les écoles
élémentaires et dans les collèges je
souhaiterais savoir si vous avez analysé
ne serait-ce que dans votre région quel
serait le prix euh pour vous par élève
afin de pouvoir euh accompagner ses
élèves dans cette tenue scolaire
identique je vous en remercie merci
Christine harigi pour le groupe
écologiste
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la présidente des régions de France
alors la question m'a été piquée par ma
voisine mais je vais la poser quand même
euh sur l'efficacité des régions comme
actrices de leur propre développement
qui dépend évidemment vous l'avez
indiqué des moyens et de l'autonomie
d'action qui dont elles sont quand même
pas mal privé mais également comme
beaucoup de collectivités locales et les
écologistes s'opposent évidemment à
cette dérive et notamment dans la
capacité à définir et à mettre en œuvre
une stratégie propre de par la qui va
au-delà de la question de la taille et
de la superficie ou du nombre
d'habitants alors en France on observe
déjà qu'il arrive que le budget d'une
grande ville ou métropole et
établissement associés et des moyens et
des budgets supérieurs à à une région ce
qui est quand même incroyable au regard
des compétences de chacun et la
différence entre les régions françaises
et les régions des principaux pays
européens est flagrante alors les
régions françaises pèsent peu au point
de vue financier face aux régions
européennes comparables on en a parlé
par rapport à l'Allemagne mais on peut
en parler parpp ort à la Flandre par
rapport à la Lombardie la
Catalogne et également le champ de
compéten des régions françaises est bien
plus étroit que celui de leurs
homologues européennes alors en fait il
existe une véritable différence entre
les régions françaises et cell des États
voisins partout y compris en
Grande-Bretagne au-delà de la question
d'ordre politique et de positionnement
politique et c'est des ces régions sont
des États fédérés disposent d'une forte
légitimité politique donc ma question
vous vous voyez venir c'est que savoir
si c'est un sujet qui est débattu au
sein de région de France sur la question
d'une évolution institutionnelle
notamment dans le cadre effectivement de
la mission qui a été confiée à Eric vers
cette évolution institutionnelle qui
pourrait renforcer le fédéralisme et
donner aux régions des moyens d'action
pour répondre aux défis climatiques et
sociaux et notamment des moyens d'action
pour agir sur des questions et les
grands principes tels que vous les avez
évoqués notamment les transports l'au
évidemment puisque on parlait de cela et
de façon plus pointue de façon plus
précise sur que pensez-vous de la de la
conception qu'il y a eu en France de la
répartition entre compétenence générale
de clause de compétence générale et
compétenence spécial que sur ce sujetl
nous avions des positions particulières
merci Jean-Marc Tellier pour le groupe
GDR oui merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente lors des TR
derniers mois nombreuses ont été les
régions à signé leur protocole d'accord
du contrat de plan état région mobilité
2023-2027 malgré 40 milliards d'euros
mis sur la table conjointement par
l'État et les régions soit 25 % de plus
que dans la génération précédente de
contrat certaines régions ont retarder
la conclusion les CP et les négociations
relatives au volet des
mobilités ont été particulièrement
difficiles cela s'explique entre autres
par le fait qu'il était attendu de de
l'État une participation beaucoup plus
forte pour espérer produire un choc
d'offre en faveur du train et des
mobilités et des mobilité décarboné
ainsi la hausse des moyens à hauteur de
40 milliards mis en avant ne prend pas
en compte l'inflation dans le secteur or
selon le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures la
hausse des prix s'élèvera à 27 % en se
fondant dessus les régions évaluent à
environ 28,9 milliard d'euros l'effort
que devrait fournir l'état s'agissant
des objectifs de transition climatique
là encore des résistances ont été émis
notamment sur la les faibles la
faiblesse des moyens loués par l'État
pour permettre cette transition ainsi
j'aurit deux questions quand peut-on
espérer voir mise en place un outil
relatif à l'évaluation environnementale
des CP et qu de la mise en cohérence de
cette génération de CP avec les
objectifs climatiques nationaux et
régionaux merci et enfin pour les
groupes Michel Castellani pour le groupe
lot
ouais merci président madame la
Présidente merci pour votre intervention
vous savez certainement qu'il existe
encore depuis longtemps une situation
politique de tension disons et qu'aucune
solution satisfaisante n'a été apportée
à ce qui les convenu d'appeler depuis
depuis des lustres euh le problème Corse
c'est d'ailleurs le l'enjeu majeur de
des discussions actuelles de bovau comme
vous savez
pourquoi je dis ça parce que sur le fond
la question cor se pose le problème de
la structure centralisée de l'État
l'État nation a beaucoup de qualité en
particulier celle de de traiter chacun
de de façon égale face à la loi
évidemment ce qui est la base de la
démocratie mais il a le défaut de ne
pouvoir prendre en compte la grande
diversité territoriale de la France de
traiter de façon identique des
situations qui qui elles sont sont très
différentes et nous encore nous nous
envoyons les limites tous les jours
alors ma question est très générale
considérez-vous que faire évoluer le
rapport de compétence entre l'État
central et les territoires c'est un mode
de défaire la France de l'affaiblir
comme chacun le redoute ou au contraire
de de faciliter une politique qui soit
plus efficace plus adaptée aux
conditions géographiques économiques
sociales culturelles des régions qui
composent et qui enrichissent d'ailleurs
la France moi j'ai toujours en mémoire
ce que me disait à l'époque il était
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérard colon il
me disait vous êtes bien gentil avec vos
histoires de Corse mais les Bretons ont
déjà la main sur le stylo
je cite bon c'est cette crainte de voir
la France s'effondrer alors qu'en fait
nous nous pensons que l'approche doit
être différente et qu' s'agit au
contraire de valoriser ce qui fait la
richesse et la diversité de la France
j'aimerais vous interroger là-dessus du
haut de votre expérience de
présidente Merci à VOUS Carole delgard
on aura quelques questions
supplémentaires après mais je propose de
répondre maintenant au
groupes donc sur la la question du bilan
des nouvelles régions
des des grandes régions euh ce qui euh a
été clairement euh évalué et démontré
c'est la capacité d'entraînement
beaucoup plus forte sur la question des
filières économiques nous avons réussi
de par la taille de de de région plus
importante à mieux structurer des
filières industrielles à faire en sorte
qu'elle maille mieux le territoire ou
développer de nouvelles filières en
particulier sur la question des énergies
renouvelables et tout particulièrement
de de l'hydrogène vert cela n'a été
possible de par cette capacité parce que
quand on doit créer une nouvelle filière
on on doit en fait créer une filière sur
toute la chaîne c'est-à-dire aussi bien
sur la question de la la production de
la distribution des usages et les
tailles plus grandes de de région ont
permis d'avoir une dynamique économique
plus forte d'avoir un travail qui so
soit mieux organisé avec les consulaires
avec les les branches
professionnelles la Cour des comptes
ayant étudié ce sujet donc le bilan de
ces grandes régions au point de vue
économique est positif et il a été aussi
démontré qu'il y a eu donc un
investissement plus grand au niveau des
mobilités c'est-à-dire les dépenses les
les économies qui ont été faites sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement ont été
affecté
prioritairement sur l'investissement
dans les mobilités sur les économies
elles ont été
donc chiffré à 2 milliards d'euros pour
les régions et on vous en fournira le
détail sur les différentes politiqu sur
la question de la formation il y a
qu'une seule région qui n'avait pas
contractualisé euh au niveau des prix
c'est la région Auvergne ronalpe toutes
les autres régions ont contractualisé la
région paka il a eu un dispositif un peu
dérogatoire mais qui euh objectivement
s'inspirait quand même des des des prix
donc les ces prixes ont profondément
évolué parce que la structuration du
chômage a beaucoup évolué en 8 ans nous
avions un taux de chômage très élevé qui
demandait prioritairement de développer
le nombre de places de formation
aujourd'hui nous sommes plus du tout sur
les mêmes besoins et nous sommes sur des
formations qui sont plus longues et et
qui touche prioritairement des chômeurs
de de longue durée et nous allons
voir la les nouvelles dispositions
opérationnelles de France le travail au
niveau de région de France nous avons
été assez déçus sur les ces évolution où
nous avons jugé qu'il y avait un manque
de souplesse pour pouvoir adapter nos
politiques de formation au bassin
d'emploi parce que nous avons des
situations qui sont très très
différentes d'un territoire au l'autre
au sein même d'un département sur la
question de le de la
formation je me permets de de rappeler à
Madame dalos que la région intervient
sur tout ce qui est formation initiale
au niveau des des lycées euh de façon
significative au niveau quand même de
l'enseignement supérieur au niveau quand
même des demandeurs d'emploi et puis
également et de plus en plus au niveau
de la formation des des salariés et dans
les propositions que nous avons donc
élaboré donc c'était pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 nous avons
suggéré que il y ait au niveau de la
formation des outils communs qui
puissent être utilisé en particulier en
matière de plateau technique pour la
formation initiale pour la formation des
demandeur d'emploi ou pour la formation
continue parce que nous avons une
évolution sociétale forte à laquelle il
faut savoir répondre c'est-à-dire nous
avons des salariés qui veulent avoir
plusieurs métiers dans une vie avoir
plusieurs métiers dans une une vie
c'est-à-dire avoir des réorientations de
carrière qui sont vraiment très très
différentes et aujourd'hui le le système
qui a mis en place la séparation entre
formation initiale formation des
demandeurs d'emploi et formation des
salariés n'est pas opérationnel et ne
correspond pas à ces formations tout au
long de la vie qui peuvent être vraiment
de
façon très très différente c'est-à-dire
c'est l'ingénieur qui souhaite devenir
agriculteur c'est le commerçant qui veut
devenir enseignant et donc ce sont pas
des formations d'adaptation ce sont des
formations qui sont lourdes et qui
aujourd'hui sont possibles dans des
grandes entreprises parce que les
grandes entreprises ont les moyens de
financer ces dispositifs et dans les PME
et TPE il y a une vraie inégalité et
souvent est utilisée la rupture
conventionnelle pour pouvoir en fait
financer ces ces formations de
réorientation de viis par des créit
crédit de demandeur d'emploi et cela est
parfaitement inutile et c'est pour cela
que je je pense que dans le domaine de
la formation les les régions ont un
poids important en effet l'État en a
également mais je me permets de vous
rappeler que nous sur les demandeurs
d'emploi nous sommes en partenariat
vraiment très très significatif que les
formations collectives sont assumées sur
des
crédits région euh et que nous avons cet
enjeu de réfléchir euh à à une nouvelle
un nouveau paradigme sur euh l'envie de
euh des salariés d'avoir plusieurs
métiers différents dans euh dans une vie
et de savoir mutualiser pardon des
plateau euh euh technique donc les pour
la question des prix ils sont euh là je
pense qu'on est aussi sur un/3 des des
des des contrats qui doivent être
finalisés à peu près je sous le ils sont
quasiment tous sur le mond sur l'annexe
financement oui voilà c'est-à-dire que
sur le contenu on est à peu près
d'accord avec le ministère du travail
mais c'est avec les les financements il
y a un accord que sur le financement
pour un/ers des des des régions euh au
niveau des euh mobilité au niveau des
des mobilités euh nous en avions parlé
sur la multiplicité des des acteurs euh
au niveau des dispositifs de de
prévention euh par rapport au aux
épisodes climatiques sur la question des
des mobilités c'est aussi ce facteur là
en particulier sur les territoires
urbain qui est un éclatement des des
acteurs qui n'est pas du tout favorable
à l'enchaînement des mobilités
collectives c'està-dire à proposer un
parcours de mobilité de porte à porte
simplifié c'est-à-dire qu'on est sur un
territoire urbain c'est au-delà de la
question juste métropolitaine
c'est-à-dire on parle sur le le bassin
de vie nous avons plusieurs acteurs donc
nous avons sur le ferroviaire je le
rappelle bon bien sûr la SNCF les
régions l'état parce que les toutes les
lignes ne sont pas de la enfin sont
toutes propriété de l'État mais elles
sont pas toutes de la responsabilité de
financement de l'État il y en a
certaines pour les régions donc déjà
nous avons trois intervenants sur le
ferrovire nous avons ensuite
tram métro voilà qui sont et bus qui
sont de compétences métropolitaines
compéten métropolitaines c'est-à-dire
qui ne s'applique pas à l'échelle du
bassin de vie c'est-à-dire des
territoires qui ne sont pas dans un
territoire métropolitain sont exclus de
transport collectif type tram métro et
bus et puis nous avons la question donc
descarts
l'écart au-delà donc l'écart c'est
moyenne et longue distance euh Lescart
sont de la responsabilité des régions
mais les régions ne sont pas
responsables des routes c'est-à-dire que
quand je veux
augmenter ma desserte par car parce
qu'il n'y a pas de rail à ce moment-là
je dois aller voir les propriétaires des
routes qui peuvent être l'état l'état
concédé les autoroutes les départements
les
métropoles et je leur demande à ce
momentlà de me mettre à disposition des
routes que je ne finance pas voyez le
succès que nous pouvons avoir quand nous
sommes prés président de de région et
c'est pourquoi nous avons proposé
l'ensemble des présidents de région
qu'il y ait des agences desmobilité à
l'échelle des aires urbaines pour avoir
une cohérence
d'action une cohérence d'action sur la
question des mobilités ce n'est il n'est
pas du tout question de reproduire
île-de-fance mobilité à l'échelle des
territoires urbains de de province nous
serions bien sur l'investissement euh
ces agences d'mobilité n'auraient pas
les missions de définir par exemple les
arrêts de bus n sont pas là mais c'est
d'avoir une cohérence de
l'investissement et tout
particulièrement par exemple sur les
voies réservées pour euh au niveau
routier parce que nous avons en effet à
à progresser sur l'aspect du ferroviaire
mais par exemple sur les services de car
euh la possibilité technique comme cela
existe dans d'autres pays ou de façon
expérimentale sur des certains
territoires comme le territoire no blis
c'est d'ailleurs d'avoir des voies
réservées pour le covoiturage et pour
l'écart et si on avait une enfin unité
une agence qui permet de négocier ça
nous permettrait d'avra d'avoir un
service beaucoup plus renforcé sur des
mobilités collectives qui sont
absolument indispensables parce que nous
n'avons pas des des donc des rail dans
tous les territoires et nous devons
proposer le covoiturage et euh le cas et
avoir des voies réservées pour donner
une priorité à celles et ceux qui
prennent des
transport collectif c'est cela figure
également mais je vous transmettrai
monsieur le Président donc le livre
blanc hein sur ces propositions de
région que nous
avons mis en place euh sur la question
des des mobilités pour simplifier et
puis je le rappelle il faut avoir une
simplicité du parcours avec un titre
unique et avec ça c'est une ça c'est pas
une proposition région de France mais
pour ma part avec une
tarification très basse voilà donc dans
dans tous les cas le par contre la
question d'une d'un billet unique est
porté par l'ensemble des présidents de
de région pour avoir une simplicité du
parcours je prends le train puis le
métro puis le vélo et en fait qui est
avec un titre unique de transport une
fluidité
interdépartementale voilà donc même
interrg régionale pour vraiment
simplifier le parcours des des mobilités
euh la région Occitanie n'est pas la
seule région concernée par les LGV je
vous rappelle que la région paka
également concernée puisque nous avons
trois projets de LGV Marseille Nice donc
Bordeaux Toulouse Bordeaux Dax et
Montpellier
Perpignan nous avons la nécessité de
rappeler que si nous voulons plus de
transport du quotidien nous avons ont
besoin de nouvelles voies et je suis
assez étonné sur ce territoire dans
lequel vous vivez monsieur le député que
vous ne mentionnez pas que c'est le
territoire ferroviaire le plus saturé de
France c'est-à-dire la
ligne A zé Lig sur sur mon territoire
non mais sur votre territoire de façon
de vie de bassin de vie je parle pas
juste de votre circonscription en tant
que député de de la nation donc je vous
rappelle que l'axe Montpellier Narbon
est le plus saturé de France c'est le
plus saturé de c'est le plus saturé de
France donc nous avons besoin d'avoir
une deuxème ligne pour des transports du
quotidien c'est également le cas sur
l'aire urbaine toulousen et ce que nous
défendons les présidents de région ce
sont des transports sur des aires
urbaines qui soient sur des dis distance
de 50 à 60 km et certainement pas sur 20
km d'où la nécessité d'avoir des
deuxièmes ligne ferroviaire euh qui soit
mixte je précise bien parce que nous
avons aussi euh la
problématique du de la saturation en
terme de poids lourd sur les autoroutes
que ça soit pour le corridor
méditerranéen que ça soit pour le
corridor Atlantique je pense tout
particulièrement à Bordeaux d'X
également don des lignes qui permettent
d'augmenter les transports du quotidien
des lignes qui permettent d'avoir une
vraie solution sur le fret ferroviaire
et nous avons donc besoin de ces LGV
pour favoriser ces mobilités nous avons
de plus sur le portour méditerranéen la
question de la submersion régulière de
des lignes de la ligne ferroviaire
actuelle et malheureusement avec les
prévisions sur l'espace méditerranéen
qui est un des plus impactés sur la
planète avec la montée des eau et
c'est-à-dire la submersion qui existe
déjà aujourd'hui avec des ruptures de la
desserte ferroviairees qui sont
plusieurs fois par an sur ces
territoires autour du bassin
méditerranéen là je parle aussi bien de
Marseille Nice que de Montpellier
Perpignan mais nous avons la nécessité
absolue d'avoir une autre ligne et je
rappelle que cette grande vitesse est la
même que ça soit en Occitanie ou en
région PACA et je pense que donc il ne
faut pas opposer LGV et et train de du
quotidien nous avons besoin euh des deux
et sur la
question de du viaduc qui est envisagé
quand nous sommes sur de la grande
vitesse nous avons des rayons de
courbure qui ne qui ne peuvent pas être
trop prononcés et donc nous avons besoin
de cela et moi je suis très attaché dans
notre pays à une une égalité et dans les
Pyrénées Orientales je me permets de
vous rappeler qu'ils sont à plus de 5h30
de Paris et que le billet d'avion est à
plus de 500 EUR c'est un des
départements les plus pauvres de France
c'est un département où le taux de
chômage est le de nouveau sur l'année
2023 le plus élevé de France et je pense
que nous devons savoir
concilier donc écologie et sociale c'est
absolument indispensable pour que il n'y
ait pas de désespoir et que les valeurs
républicaines soient toujours les les
gagnantes sur le r des Pyrénées parce
que je pense que monsieur le député des
Hautes Pyrénées me parlait de de ce
sujet je je pense le titre est très beau
et la pyrénen que je suis est bien sûr
sensible mais il faut aussi être lucide
voilà un RER c'est sur un bassin de
population qui permet de répondre à un
cadencement et donc c'est un territoire
que que je connais fort bien puisque j'y
vis et autant je connais la nécessité de
réouvrir une ligne ferroviaire tel que
montrégeot Luchon autant un r des
Pyrénées cela n'est pas réaliste ni
raisonnable il n'y a pas de besoin si
vous voulez je lesi indiqué à Monsieur
le Maire de lourde j'ai donné les
chiffres de de fréquentation et les
chiffres d'extrapolation parce que je
connais aussi que quand un service est
très dégradé il y a une population qui
prend peu bien sûr le le service de
mobilité mais sur ce
territoire des des Pyrénées il n'y a pas
le besoin d'un d'un RER il faut voilà
être très ObjC objectif sur ce sujet
pour ce qui est l'occcitanie j'ai
indiqué que la région se porterait
candidate et sur l'air urbaine
toulousaine et sur l'air montpeliieren
il y a une réflexion aussi sur l'aire
urbaine nimoise mais qui doit être
portée en relation avec la région PACA
puisque nous avons la vallée du du rô en
commun et là il faut qu'on ait une
vision
interrégionale à à
construire
sur la question également du bâtiment
oui nous nous sommes également très
préoccupés sur l'effondrement de la
construction de la construction
individuel en particulier c'est pourquoi
nous pensons absolument indispensable
que les régions maintiennent un haut
niveau d'investissement pour la
réhabilitation énergétique des lycées
pour également l'accessibilité parce que
nous avons quand même encore voilà de de
gros travaux à mener sur l'accessibilité
de nos bâtiments qui pour certaines
dates du 19e siècle sont pas du tout
adaptés aux normes et puis également
pour la la la sécurisation et euh nous
avons été plusieurs président de de
région à réfléchir et pour certains à
mettre en œuvre des plans sur le le
bâtiment durable c'est-à-dire à four à
soutenir la production de logements en
dehors des métropoles pour favoriser un
rééquilibrage territorial à également
euh soutenir des euh techniques
constructive euh durable euh pour
réutiliser de nouvelles techniques moins
consommatrices d'énergie l'utilisation
de matériaux aussi biosourcés et tout un
volet de formation que nous travaillons
avec Fédération française du bâtiment ou
avec le la CAPEB adapté et là aussi qui
sont délocalisé sur les bassins d'emploi
et je pourrais euh puisque la la premier
plan voter le Plan Bâtiment Durable de
la région Occitanie je pourrais vous
fournir ce dispositif qui euh comprend
ce sujet et avec un volet aussi sur le
beau euh dans la question euh de de
l'habitat de pouvoir concilier
esthétique urbain euh et euh également
efficacité énergétique et d'avoir aussi
une réflexion sur le vivre ensemble à
travers le l'urbanisme comme cela peut
être fait euh euh en Espagne ou dans des
pays d'Amérique du Sud et je ne serai
pas plus longue parce que là c'est ma
passion pour l'urbanisme qui se qui se
développe et c'est pas l'objet de votre
de votre question
eu oui juste sur les les CP pour qu'ilit
pas de mal entendu il y a 1/ers du volet
mobilité des CP des régions qui l'ont
pas encore qui il y a juste 1/3 des
régions qui ont signé le volet mobilité
des CP tous les autres CP ont été signés
c'est sur le volet mobilité des CPR
qu'il n'y a qu'un tiers des régions qui
l'ont signé où il y a eu un terme clair
un accord financier et il y a 2 tiers
des régions qui n'ont pas encore
d'accord financiers
[Musique]
h toujours sur les politiques euh oui
sur la tenue identique dans les dans les
lycées il n'y a que la région Auvergne
ronalpe je ne veux pas dire oui c'est ça
il y'y a que la région romigne Auvergne
ronalp qui a souhaité expérimenter dans
de mémoire
je
non non parce que la Région auverneurnal
finance les
oui non parce qu'après vous avez des des
des communes ou des des départements
mais la seule région qui finance euh des
tenues identiques c'est la région au
Verne
ronalpe et je crois que c'est sur 10
lycées je veux pas dire si il me semble
que c'est sur une dizaine de de lycées
euh donc pour ma part j'ai j'ai indiqué
à l'époque au ministre de l'éducation
nationale euh que je souhaitais
poursuivre l'investissement et orienter
le budget de de l'occcitanie sur la
rénovation énergétique l'accessibilité
la sécurisation et que si j'avais des
marges de manœuvre budgétaire lié à une
baisse de de l'inflation je souhaitais
l'orienter sur la cantine scolaire voilà
parce que dans le projet que que nous
avions cétait et de baisser le coût de
la cantine scolaire pour les familles
modestes et et moyennes voilà
h
sur la question du budget vert
eu il y avait jusqu'en 2023 trois
régions qui
avaient mis en place des budget vert don
don l'occcitanie
euh courant 2023
il y en a trois de plus qu'il avait
développé donc on en était
voilà donc à la moitié
eu et donc là nous
attendons la la
circulaire qui va euh voilà donc nous
demander un travail d'adaptation et nous
souhaiterions que cette circulaire
s'inspire des budgets verts qui existe
déjà pour ne pas recréer de nouvelles
nomenclatures qui sont quand même euh
consommatrices de beaucoup de temps pour
nos euh fonctionnaires euh voilà
euh sur
[Musique]
euh la qu'est-ce que j'ai écrit
oui sur la le la la question de la
substitution de la fiscalité automobile
la fiscalité voiture ce que nous
défendons euh c'est d'avoir une
fiscalité qui est euh plus liée à la à
la dynamique euh économique
et nous défendons en effet une autonomie
réglementaire tout particulièrement pour
la Corse et pour les territoires
d'outrem et euh je je pense également
qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir une plus
grande autonomie financière c'est la la
position de région de France c'est de
lier une plus grande autonomie
réglementaire prioritairement sur
territoire d'outrem et Corse mais pas
uniquement euh et autonomie financière
et comme je l'aiindiquais euh de le
coupler avec autonomie fiscale ça c'est
une position que juste certains
présidents de région dont je fais partie
défend euh sur la question du du
fédéralisme il n'y a à ce jour aucun
président de région qui souhaite aller
vers ce modèle- làà donc dans les
proposition euh que nous allons
Actualiser pour la mission verte nous
n'avons pas de proposition sur ce sujet
nous sommes très attachés à la
République une et indivisible mais avec
une une autre autonomie beaucoup plus
forte comme cela peut exister dans
d'autres dans d'autres
pays donc les propositions sur la Eric
vert je m'a contacté en décembre c'est
une conversation téléphonique nous
devons nous rencontrer pour une réunion
de travail puisque je lu ai fait passer
le livre blanc des régions et on doit
avoir une réunion de travail qui va être
fixé pardon oui oui donc qui va être
fixé d'ici 15 jours 3 semaines hein pour
travailler les propositions que je lui
ai fait passer sur la question des
mobilités je vous les ai présenté avec
Agence des mobilités sur la question de
la formation je voulais présenter
également et puis les autres
propositions portent sur les les sujets
de l'orientationin où nous voudrions
qu'il y ait voilà beaucoup plus de
possibilités d'ouvrir euh le collège et
le lycée à la découverte de l'ensemble
des des métiers et également sur sur les
dispositifs d'information sur les les
formations il y a des initiatives qui
sont menées par certaines région
également pour dans les lycées de
pouvoir mettre des formations
spécifiques pour des études considéré
seulement comme difficile par exemple
sur les études de médecine qui puissent
y avoir vraiment une
vraie une vraie préparation dans le
cadre des d'une préparation publique
hein que soit bien clair que nous
souhaiterions et euh ensuite nous avons
été enfin nous sommes très préoccupés
sur l'inégalité euh
entre les lycées sur la question des
options puisque nous voyons bien que les
territoires en les les lycées dans les
centres-villes de de grande métropole
peuvent proposer un choix beaucoup plus
large que dans les territoires ruraux et
là l'ensemble des présidents de région
sont préoccupés sur sur ce sujetl là
[Musique]
euh oui sur la la la question de des
clauses de de de de compétences
générales nous sommes voilà plutôt
favorables à ce que sur les donc les
compétences partagées qui sont le
tourisme la culture et le sport il y a
un un chef de fila hein voilà c'est mais
que mais que nous soyons pas sur une une
spécialisation puisque aujourd'hui sur
ces trois compétences nous sommes toutes
les collectivités locales à intervenir
et c'est plutôt la la notion de chef de
fila je crois que j'ai répondu sur
l'emploi j'ai pas entendu de si si si
l'emploi j'ai
répondu voilà je je pense que j'ai
répondu à peu près à tout on va passer
aux questions SP je suis content de
d'apprendre qu'on a temps d'avance sur
l'ancien président de la commission des
finances voilà il va peut-être regarder
les vidéos ilura
peut-être un certain nombre
d'informations
euh on passe à donc une minute Caren
Rodi merci monsieur le Président Madame
Delga en tant que président de
l'Association des régions de France vous
mettez en avant votre gestion financière
celle-ci s'inscrit dans un cadre
austéritaire imposé par l'État vous êtes
particulièrement attentive à limiter
cette dette des régions il vous faut
donc faire des choix et vos choix
politiques m'interrogent en quoi est-
pertinent que d'un côté certaines
régions suppriment des dotations
destinées aux universités et que de
l'autre côté d'autres régions s'ent dê à
financer des projets inutiles éccid et à
rebours de la burcation écologique je
parle ici bien sûr de la 69 dont vous
êtes une fervante défenseur et plus
spécifiquement le coût du péage que
cette autoroute et plus spécifiquement
le coût du péage de cette autoroute
m'interpelle un allerretour reviendrait
à plus de 19 €. la région va-elle
s'engager à participer financièrement à
la baisse du coût de ce péage la R et si
oui ce serait un tour de passe-pe
astucieux le concessionnaire avait
pourtant prétendu pouvoir se passer de
90 % des subventions initiales cette
autoroute n'est pas rentable et vous le
savez il n'y aura pas assez de véhicules
par jour qui l'emprunteront donc
pourquoi la défend à tout prix votre
autoroute personne n'en veut ni la
majorité des citoyens des entreprises
des scientifiques des élus elle est
aussi contraire aux enjeux climatiques
et à la formation des ingénieurs en TR
public merci Michel
lezana
allô oui merci euh merci madame la
Présidente merci d'avoir gardé votre bel
accent notre bel accent euh vous avez
démontré je crois euh en effet la
nécessité d'une d'une ligne à grande
vitesse et je suis élu d'agin donc bien
concerné par la ligne à grande vitesse
Bordeaux bordeau Toulouse que je crois
absolument nécessaire à la fois pour un
département le mien qui est assez pauvre
et rural mais aussi pour les les
départements qui nous entourent et ce
qui vous concerne le nord du Gers qui
vient sur la Gené bien évidemment le
donc vous vous êtes exprimé là-dessus
alors je vais transformer un peu ma
question en vous demandant ce que vous
pensez euh du refus de certaines
collectivités de de financer cette ligne
à grande vitesse et certaines
collectivités qui elles ont tourné entre
guillemets en finançant que des
infrastructures locales voilà quelle est
votre position sur sur ce financement
deuxème point madame la Présidente nous
avons ici et cela me tient
particulièrement à cœur en tant que
médecin un groupe de travail sur la
formation en santé c'est un enjeu majeur
pour moi pour combattre la
désertification et il se trouve que par
exemple à agin la le la région très
rapidement je termine ne finance pas
l'école d'infirmière d'apprentissage les
les pierricultrus les les les
ambulanciers quelle est votre doctrine
là-dessus parce que je crois que c'est
vraiment un outil très utile pour la
pour lutter contre la désertification
merci je rappelle que Carole Delga étaé
invité ici en tant que présidente de
l'Association des région de France
Laurent esquinet goxes c'est ça à qui je
souhaite la bienvenue merci monsieur le
président madame la Présidente Delga
cherre Carole je suis heureux de vous
retrouver ici à l'Assemblée nationale
car nous partageons tous les deux
l'attachement à l'Occitanie à la haute
Garon que ce soit à martrot Lausane
Villefanche de l'oraguet ou à Toulouse
on peut faire un concours d'accent je
don à venir vous saluer bien que je ne
siège pas habituellement dans cette
commission plus sérieusement vous avez
évoqué la nécessité de renforcer l'
économie des collectivités c'est un
sujet majeur pour notre majorité qui a
engagé ça a été dit tout à l'heure des
travaux d'ampleur en vue d'une nouvelle
vague de
décentralisation ma question vous
plaidez pour renforcer les pouvoirs
économiques des régions sur quel point
précis pensez-vous qu'il vous faut
renforcer ses compétences en la matière
pour des industries de taille
international comme l'aéronautique par
exemple je pourrais aussi citer le
spatial pour notre territoire comment
assurer le renforcement du pouvoir local
et qui s'articule bien avec les
ambitions portées au National européens
ou mondial je vous remercie merci Fabien
di
Philippo merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente pendant toutes nos
discussions budgettaire ici et bien
notamment monsieur le rapporteur général
du budget soulignit la nécessité pour
les régions par rapport au fait qu'elle
serait favorisé sur le plan financier
avec des recettes sur le plan économique
notamment relativement dynamique à
contribué au désendettement de de l'État
quelle est la position votre position
celle de région de France par rapport à
ça sur la situation financière et l'qu
avec les compétences de nos
collectivités locales et sur le fait que
bientôt vous puissiez être mis à
contribution soit par le biaet de
ponction fiscale soit pour le de
ponction financière soit par le billet
de l'attribution de nouvelles
compétences merci Véronique louvagi
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente pour les éléments que vous
nous avez fournis j'ai deux questions
une première sur la gestion plus
exactement la distribution des fonds
européens puisque maintenant les fonds
européens de la politique générale ne
sont plus distribués uniquement par
l'État comme c'était le le cas est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire un petit
point sur les modalités de mise en œuvre
ces dernières années et sur le taux
d'exécution et j'ai une deuxième
question qui concerne les CPE donc vous
nous avez donné je dirais un un agenda
et une description des des modalités de
mise en œuvre des CP en cours est-ce que
vous pouvez nous faire un point sur la
sous-exécution éventuelle ou le taux
d'exécution des précédence CP je vous
remercie merci d'autres
questions Charles syen stool ah oui
j'avais carrément oublié au
début
désolé merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente alors comme nous
sommes en commission des finances moi je
voudrais faire mention d'un rapport de
la cour des compte celui de 2023 sur les
40 ans de la décentralisation rapport
passionnant qui pointe les avancées mais
aussi les nombreuses lacune de la
décentralisation à la française et dans
son rapport la Cour dresse un bilan
mitigé de la création des grandes
régions voulues par François Hollande je
cite des grandes régions plus éloignées
des citoyens c'est la Cour des comptes
elle-même qui le dit et ce jugement pose
beaucoup de questions dans dans un pays
effectivement en pleine crise
démocratique les grandes régions n'ont
pas conduit à des gains d'efficience
attendu ça aussi c'est la Cour des
comptes qui le dit et la Cour reconnaît
que les grandes régions manque aussi
d'un ancrage historique et politique qui
constitue pourtant un élément essentiel
de leur légitimité dans les pays qui
disposent de régions plus plus
puissantes la création des nouvelles
grandes régions a parfois eu un sens je
pense à la Normandie mais dans d'autres
territoires comme dans le mien en Alsace
beaucoup de questions se posent toujours
et nous souhaitons en Alsace je tiens à
le dire retrouver notre région merci
donc cette fois-ci est- qu'il y a
d'autres questions une fois deux fois
trois fois Carol Caro delg à
vous sur la question de de la
désertification
médicale les régions ont des politiques
différentes il y a trois régions qui ont
décidé de recruter elles-mêmes des
médecins la première région c'était la
région centrevde Loire qui a débuté dès
2019 à recruté des des médecins et donc
en occiitanie nous en sommes inspirés et
la région auvergner ronalpe également
l'a débuté en en 2023 donc nous avons
décidé les régions de pouvoir recruter
des médecins pour les mettre à dispos
position dans des centres de santé parce
que cela permet d'être plus attractif
euh puisque les ces médecins qu'ils soit
jeune ou qu'il soit en fin de carrière
apprécie le fait de pouvoir être dans le
cadre d'un collectif et puis également
d'avoir d'être salarié avec une
collectivité locale qui assure leur
rémunération de façon pérenne puisque
euh jusqu'à jusqu'à cette initiative de
la la
région Centre val-deloire c'était
souvent les intercommunalités qui
recrutaient et il y avait une véritable
concurrence et donc une inégalité entre
les intercommunalités qui étaient riches
qui pouvaient proposer des primes de
façon élevée et des territoire qui étit
en difficulté et qui eux donc de fait
n'étent pas attractif à cause de la la
rémunération d'avoir un recrutement à
l'échelle d'une grande région donc de
comme enfin 12 départements comme AA ou
ou comme Occitanie euh cela permet
d'avoir une meilleure égalité euh donc à
l'accès à à la santé et ça c'est un
sujet que Don nos concitoyens nous
parlent régulièrement euh ensuite
clairement les présidents région qui ont
mis en place ce dispositif donc les
trois l'ont fait parce que l'État ne le
fait pas mais voilà pour ma part je
pense que c'était à l'état de de le
faire et j'étais dans l'obligation de de
répondre euh à cette déprise qui étaità
pour moi euh particulièrement injuste et
très préoccupante par pour n nos
concitoyens donc les présidents de
région l'ont fait parce que euh nous
avons proposé au ministère de la Santé
ça n'a pas été fait mais je pense que ça
c'est une mission en fait nous pensons
les trois que c'est une mission que
l'État devrait assurer sur le
financement des écoles d'infirmiers
d'infirmière je pense que c'est une
obligation donc ça m'étonne
que c'est l'apprentissage mais en fait
c'est c'est la formation en
périphérique formation teroire ou oui
alors donc ça c'est l'implantation en
effet de des centres de de formation les
présidents de région nous y sommes très
attachés de créer de petites unités de
formation sur des bassins euh de vie
pour éviter des longs trajets qui sont
souvent non finançables par des
personnes qui sont en difficulté et qui
en plus ont un impact aussi
environnemental pour autant le
dispositif de parcours sup a vraiment
déstructuré la dynamique je tiens à vous
alerter sur ce sujet donc je vous
remerci d'avoir posé la question sinon
j'allais oublié de le mentionner
parcours sup a cassé cette dynamique des
centres de formation de de proximité
parce que à travers le dispositif qui
existait avec des centres de formation
et tout particulièrement sur les écoles
d'aide soignant d'IDE soignante ou
d'infirmers ou d'infirmière avant qu'il
y ait parcours sup les les les
recrutements était en fonction des des
concours et il y avait une donc une
motivation de pouvoir après être en
école de formation sur ses métiers à la
santé en proximité et après sur un
territoire souvent qui était rural avec
parcours sup il y a une déconnexion
complètement entre l'origine
territoriale de de ces apprenants et ses
écoles de de formation et euh de plus
nous savons très bien que les métiers
euh de de soins à la personne sont des
vocations et euh un algorithme ne peut
pas juger de la vocation et j'en ai fait
part à à Madame la Ministre de de
l'enseignement supérieur parce que nous
avons un taux d'abandon dans ces écoles
des métiers de la santé qui est très
significatif et qui en terme budgétaire
je je sais que nous sommes dans la
commission fin finire donc il y a une
conséquence c'est-à-dire que nous
dimensionnons euh nos classes nos
équipements pour un certain effectif et
au mois de juin nous avons perdu un/3 de
l'effectif voilà parce que
les les métiers de soins à la personne
sont des des métiers qui qui demandent
une vraie vocation
et souvent la confrontation avec la
maladie tout particulièrement dans les
maisons de retraite est parfois très
difficile pour les les candidats et et
les candidates il n'y a pas assez de de
préparation et cela c'est un biais de de
parcours sup qui est significatif et qui
casse cette politique que nous avions
mis les présid président de Région de
centre de formation en proximité qui
permettait d'amener une réponse sur les
établissements de santé dans milieu
rural qui permettaiit aussi de lutter
contre le déterminisme social vous êtes
dotgaron vous connaissez donc assez bien
l'occcitanie je vais vous citer un
exemple dans le Lot sur un
territoire de fijac pendant des années
il n'y avait aucun candidat aucun
candidat je dis bien à l'école
d'infirmière de caor du moment que nous
avons créé une école d'infirmière à
fijac nous avons rempli dès la 2è année
l'intégralité de la classe c'est-à-dire
que la proximité permet de lutter contre
le le le déterminisme social et ça c'est
vraiment sur le la question des soins à
la personne notre service de public de
santé qui est en grande difficulté ça
c'est un vrai un vrai sujet donc là on a
un billet avec parcours sup qui qui est
complexe voil qui est complexe et sur
lesquel cela nous pose des problèmes y
compris en terme budgétairees même si la
question de la santé vous comprenez que
je naborde généralement pas sur l'aspect
du du coût mais nous avons cette
problématique de l'abandon qui est très
significatif et je me permets de
vraiment d'attirer votre attention en
tant que représentant de de la nation
euh sur la la compétence économie et sur
la question d'une d'une meilleure
intervention des régions je le dis
souvent à à Bruno Le Maire et donc je
continuer à à lui dire le nombre
d'appels à projet voilà qui partent de
Bercy pour les entreprises c'est tout
simplement délirant voilà c'est tout
simplement délirant et cela ne
favorisent que les grandes entreprises
parce que les PME les TPE n'ont pas les
services qui peuvent suivre l'ensemble
des dispositifs alors les agences
régionales que nous avons nous le
faisons mais même quand mes
collaborateurs sont sont perdus dans le
Maqui des appels à projets et j'ai la
chance d'avoir des collaborateurs
extrêmement compétents je n'ose vous
dire la question d'un TPE ou PME et
c'est pour ça que je pense que nous
devons avoir un état plus délocalisé et
plus décentralisé sur la question
économique c'est vraiment un dispositif
beaucoup trop important de la part des
ministères avec des process qui sont
complexes et qui bénéficient toujours à
des entreprises qui sont très
structurées et qui ne permettent pas
d'avoir une vraie irrigation des des
territoires et sur la compétence
économie nous pensons que l'État doit
rester sur la question des entreprises
en difficulté par rapport bien sûr à la
fiscalité et aux exonérations au
temporisations fiscales qui peuvent être
mis en place pour des des entreprises en
difficulté mais après ne plus intervenir
sur l'aspect de l'accompagnement
économique que ça soit aussi bien au
niveau de l'investissement que ce soit
aussi bien des outils financiers puisque
nous avons l'expertise sur l'ingénierie
finan financi au niveau de nos agences
de développement économique ou que ce
soit au niveau de la de la formation
comme je l'ai
rappelé sur la question de de la
participation des
collectivités locales au déficit de de
l'État voilà nous avons rappelé que nous
étions tous les présidents de région
attachés au principe de nontelle donc
tout dispositif inspiré du contrat de
Chor ne ne retient pas notre attention
ni notre euh
agrément sur euh les CP on pourra vous
donner les taux d'exécution au niveau
des crédits régionaux euh ils sont
exécutés de façon vraiment tout à fait
satisfaisante pour ce qui est des
crédits des régions il y a souvent quand
même un retard en particulier au niveau
des du routier sur les crédits euh de
l'État euh sur la la question des
crédits européens nous avons une
réorganisation quand même me permet de
d'attirer votre attention au niveau euh
euh du des dispositifs agricoles euh qui
euh voilà c'est tout récent qui risque
de poser problèmes C ces derniers jours
ou semaines il y a eu des manifestations
du monde agricole je me permet voilà
d'alerter euh votre attention sur la
grande précarité que connaissent nos
agriculteurs qui sont liés euh à
l'augmentation des matières premières
des euh des intranss à la difficulté
très sérieuse de la filière bio qui
demande à être largement soutenu et aux
questions de versements pâack en
particulier dans les territoires de
montagne al sans être trop technique qui
sont liés aux ICHN où les conditions ont
été modifiées et qui connaissent des des
des retards qui peuvent être quand même
complexes pour nos territoires agricoles
de montagne avec la question de de
l'élevage et là aussi on pourra vous
fournir les taux d'exécution des des
crédits européens alors voilà mon
délégué général Lui qui connaît donc sur
le taux d'exécution du PO du programme
opérationnel
2014-2020 nous sommes à 96 % voilà et
euh cl clac clac
ouis voilà donc c'est c'est C là donc ça
je l'ai indiqué
sur ensuite le le financement des des
collectivités locales
je pense
que la question de
relier les citoyens de faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas d'assignation ni
sociale ni territoriale et
prioritaire dans notre société et c'est
pourquoi nous défendons que il y ait des
budgets significativement augmentés pour
les mobilités de la part de l'État et de
la part de l'Europe et qu'il y ait un
New Deal ferroviaire au niveau européen
sur donc les les clés de
répartition sur la LGV dont vous parlez
toulouse- Bordeaux c'est 40 % à charge
des collectivités c'est la première fois
en France que les collectivités sont
obligées de monter à un niveau aussi
élevé la dernière LGV n'avait mobilisé
les collectivités locales qu'à hauteur
de de 30 %. je je regrette bien sûr cet
effort qui est demandé aux collectivités
locales qui est contraire à un principe
de solidarité nationale mais néanmoins
il était nécessaire de réaliser cette
infrastructure comme je l'ai indiquéis
et pour la connexion et pour enfin la
connexion à Paris et à Bruxelles et
également les trains du du quotidien
enfin sur l'autoroute Toulouse castre
madame herodi si vous voulez que nous
parlions de ce projet localement je me
tiens bien sûr à votre disposition comme
je me suis toujours tenu à la
disposition euh des des opposants pour
présenter euh les euh arguments pour
lesquels la région Occitanie est
favorable à l'autoroute Toulouse castre
de façon globale puisque je suis ici en
tant que présidente de région de France
les régions nous soutenons
l'investissement routier dans certains
territoires où il n'y a pas d'autres
solution comme c'est le cas sur le sud
du Tarne parce que nous avons des lignes
ferroviaires qui sont non électrifié ça
existe de façon significative en France
c'est le cas donc il sont si vous voulez
bien me laisser s parlé madame la
députée Rodi euh donc ils sont non
électrifiés c'est-à-dire sont des
locomotives diesel et donc c'est 100 l
au 100ang et ensuite nous avons
également des lignes ferroviaires qui
sont en voie unique ce qui ne permet pas
un cadencement surtout quand vous avez
des voies uniques qui sont sur 100 km
comme c'est le cas également sur le sud
du Tarne mais dans d'autres territoires
à ce moment-là la solution est un
aménagement routier et parfois l'état
n'accepte pas et parfois l'État état et
c'est le gouvernement Sarkozi et c'est
Nicolas Sarkozi sur ce territoire qui
avait décidé que ça serait une autoroute
et que ça serait pas la l'aménagement la
seule solution étant l'autoroute nous
prenons cette solution là et sur la
question de la tarification comme vous
le savez madame la députée j'ai demandé
deux groupes de travail à monsieur le
ministre des Transports j'attends la
nomination d'un nouveau ministre des
Transports deux groupes de travail et
sur la question de la tarification et
sur la question des compensations
environnementales et je ne manquerai pas
de Ren veler cette demande parce que je
suis en effet attaché à ce qu'il puisse
y avoir des tarifications plus basses
pour le covoiturage également pour les
quart de la région puisque je vous
rappelle qu'en Occitanie le quart est à
€. merci Carole delg merci la présidente
euh pour cette audition on se retrouve
demain en commission des finances avec
Inc banque defance au CDE merci